jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video erst mal hallo
sebastian ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon
in irgendeiner ecke hier oder so werben
video eingeblendet ich hole mal kurz aus
und euch das ganze zu erzählen weil
video klingt so schrecklich und das ist
in wirklichkeit eigentlich eine sehr
coole sache sage ich mal und zwar
abhängig bei dem youtube netzwerk studio
71 studio ansieht sie ist das netzwerk
auf youtube von prosieben und sat 1 und
prosieben starten jetzt eine neue serie
die den namen limit lässt trägt die
serie ist ein spin off von dem film
limitless und dreht sich um eine droge
die es den menschen ermöglicht 100 der
gehirn kapazität zu nutzen wie viel kann
man normalerweise dazu weißt du dass du
keine ahnung aber im beruf 13% maxi
maximal zehn prozent glaube ich kann man
von der höheren kapazität normalerweise
nutzen und somit ermöglicht die droge
dass man alles weiß alles rechnen kann
und einfach unglaublich leistungsfähig
ist und bekanntlicherweise ist wissen
gefährlich und so ist auch diese ganze
serie aufgebaut also leute wollen diese
droge haben um so schlau zu werden
auf der anderen seite gibt es leute die
es verhindern wollen der serienstart ist
morgen um 20 15 auf prosieben
also wenn ihr bock habt da reinzuschauen
ich habe alles gesagt es steht zwar
immer noch werbevideo da aber jetzt
werde ich nur diesen tag machen wo mir
halt zehn fragen gestellt werden
sebastian stellt sie und ich gebe meine
antworten also wir sind halt alle in
diesem style dann wollen wir mal
beginnen
hatte man unter sich aus 1 wenn du
zugriff auf das gesamte wissen der welt
hättest wie viel wenn du zu gebracht das
glaubt zu wissen der welt ist was
würdest du nicht wissen wollen bzw vor
welcher info hättest du kannst es ist
eine sehr interessante frage finde ich
habe so eine sache sich hiervon nicht
es gibt so dinge wie politik da ist es
teilweise ziemlich angenehm wenn man
sich nicht mit jeder klitzeklein haid
auseinandersetzen muss natürlich sollte
man im großen und ganzen bescheid wissen
ich glaube du könntest einfach kein auge
mehr zu tun wenn du wirklich alles
wüsste es auf dieser
und es ist teilweise wirklich entspannt
nicht über alles nachdenken zu müssen
und seine ruhe zu haben sage ich mal
einen anderen leuten aufgaben zu
überlassen
ich glaube dass auch ein problem was der
präsident der vereinigten staaten hat
muss einfach extrem viel weiß und extrem
viel shit und dinge die schieflaufen
mitbekommt die normale menschen einfach
nicht mitbekommen
deswegen auch barack obama acht jahre
viele neue graue haare
was würdest du tun wenn du die gedanken
seiner zuschauer lesen könnt ist
ehrliche antwort ich würde
wahrscheinlich den himmel gucken was die
leute interessiert ja ich würde würde
meinen youtube konnte daran ein bisschen
orientieren das kann man glaube ich
sagen wollt doch da solange es spaß
macht die videos noch weiter zu
produzieren ist glaube ich der wunsch
von jedem youtuber zu wissen was man
machen muss damit die leute sich
anschauen und ich denke mal wir haben
ich wüsste was ihr gerne seht dann würde
ich probieren das zu produzieren aber
wenn es jetzt natürlich so was komplett
krank ist es wie in einer badewanne mit
blues zu duschen zu hören würde ich es
nicht machen
ich würde wahrscheinlich was ähnliches
machen ja aber ich glaube auch wenn du
dir gedanken dazu schon lesen können ist
würdest du auch jeder einzelne musiker
und hab sowieso lieber schlange testflug
an dich fertig auch geschaffen was
würdest du tun wenn du der stärkste und
schnellste mensch der welt wird einfach
ist da dieses video drehen also ein ich
machen was ich mache
woran liegt das moment die pin des
traums des klubs stärksten schnellsten
mensch also in meinem aktuellen mindset
würde ich glaube ich nicht irgendwie
nicht über eine große glocke hängen oder
sowas sondern einfach weiter leben und
nicht irgendwie leute boxen oder es wird
also stärkste und schnellste mensch der
welt ist glaube ich dann gar nicht mal
so viel wert also weniger wert als alles
zu wissen glaube ich also könnte es
profisportler werden ja dass das
vielleicht irgendwann geld machen
usain bolt den arsch fahrzeuge
sprintrennen nächste frage was würdest
du tun wenn du die komplette
lebensgeschichte deiner bekannten und
schulfreunde kennen würdest
aber diese über merkt schon diese das
ganze wissen ist echt gefährlich
rechtfertige die man lieber nicht wissen
will schon wieder wir die ganze nacht um
die ohren geschlagen
drei tonnen koks ihr nach zu verkaufen
das hat echt nicht im wilden
schlafrhythmus das wollte ich niemand zu
wissen
die nächste frage ist heiß okay okay was
würdest du tun wenn du wirst das boreout
jeder junge jedes mädchen steht also
einerseits andererseits es ist also ich
denke erst mal wenn man die frage
wörtlich nimmt es gibt sachen auf die
manche leute stehen das will man gar
nicht wissen also selbst es gibt so
verrückte und abstruse vorlieben
illegale auch also ich glaube das wäre
wieder schon so was was man nicht wissen
wer aber es wäre natürlich für die
eigenen interessen für leute die mich
persönlich interessieren so deine
freundin oder wenn du irgendein mädchen
gut findest du also was dann wäre es
wahrscheinlich ziemlich praktisch aber
andererseits ist es dann wieder nicht
wissen bei anderen menschen ich glaube
halt auch also ich glaube in dem moment
wo dieses wissen in deinem kopf frei
bekommt ja hast du dir gegenüber
ein-meter-brett 66
der würde ich gern wissen was machen
muss um zu kriegen so wie machst du das
links und schalter um und den absolut
störgeräusche und irgendwas aus pferde
äpfel feuerlöscher schraubenzieher nach
dem schulbus das kommt alles auf einmal
in den kopf rein und zwischendrin so
ganz leise würde es einfach nicht
checken wir haben jetzt fünf fragen
beantworten noch eine die richtig heftig
sg wir nehmen können wie viel ist was
würdest du tun wenn du die
wirtschaftswelt kontrollieren könnte ist
die wahrscheinlichste bainbridge werden
gehört aber ich würde man denkt wieder
erstmal der reichste mensch der welt
sein würde aber wo reichtum es ist auch
armut du wirst dann im prinzip daran
schuld war das irgendwie auf der anderen
seite der welt leute verhungern
die alles unter den nagel reißt deshalb
wäre vielleicht ein guter ansatz das
seien grundflächen grundeinkommen so
dass jeder eine gewisse einfach um zu
verteilen ist alle kristalle cola aber
ich glaube so wirtschaft da gibt es
einfach es gibt einfach keine optimale
lösung also wer wider was wirklich fehlt
also vielleicht wollen manche leute
keine kohle sondern cola leute insgesamt
ihr merkt schon ist es ziemlich ziemlich
tricky mit diesem ganzen wissen wenn man
das hätte falls ihr wissen wollt wie das
sind die ganzen serie abgeht dann checkt
am besten am vierten ersten um 20.15
prosieben ab da läuft das ganz und dann
würde ich sagen ich finde das video echt
leid hat mir spaß gemacht die fragen
waren super interessant und aus dem
grund habe ich auch mitgemacht und jo
dann würde ich sagen sehen nicht einmal
die kuppe bradley cooper ist auch dabei
in der serie und bis dahin tschüss